over the past couple of years I have
called Jeremy Corbyn unelectable I have
called for his resignation and now I'm
calling for his help oh how the tables
have turned
now I believe the future of brexit may
actually rest in his hands next year
there will be a vote on the brexit deal
whether there is a second referendum a
general election or just the
parliamentary vote as a nation we will
have to decide whether leaving is worth
it or not
Corbin should come out and convince
labour supporting brexit ears the
staying in the EU is better for their
future by doing so perhaps he can stop
brexit this would appeal to moderate
Tories and supporters of many of the
smaller parties it could also be his
route to number 10 for many years Corbin
has been skeptical about the EU but I
believe he must come out and campaign
for the young people's futures the way
they have campaigned for him so because
of this I find myself once again singing
[Music]
late in December Corbin made it
absolutely clear the party would not
support staying in the EU that we had to
leave he also made it absolutely clear
that there would be no second referendum
and he did that in response to a
statement by Tom Watson he hinted that
there could be a second referendum he
jumped on that immediately now you say
you're forgetting that seven out of
labour seven out of ten labour
constituencies voted to leave it was the
beginner and you would like a lot of
Labour MPs talk about supporting
democracy the biggest Democratic vote
this country has ever had people voted
to leave the European Union and the
majority of people who voted to leave
were labour supporters it would be the
biggest betrayal of those people -
actually for Corbin to suddenly turn
into a remain party he's not it's not
gonna happen he knows what will happen
his party if he goes that way there's
and there's no evidence to show none
what's the web that the people of this
country have changed their minds and I'm
sure you can quote polls but I can quote
you just as many you God's latest five
polls the average of say there is little
different than what could give figures
but if you wanted it but it's here what
I have it too I have it right here
there's a graphic look at the graphic it
says August 2016 right 46 to 42 who
thought it was wrong January 2017 right
to leave 47 to 43 now the average of all
of those no listen the average it to all
of those polls is the 2% difference and
you know that in every poll there's a
2.5 percent margin and what all of the
posters are saying that just because
somebody thinks it we were wrong to vote
to leave it doesn't mean they think that
the referendum should be reversed in
fact they're saying the reverse 69% of
people no matter how they voted think we
should just get on with it and gout well
can I just add and then I'll bring you
in yes Fitz mica and then I'll bring you
in just a couple of things on that point
Carol like you say we could all quote
polls but I have a poll that says very
different to what you've just quoted
where 51% of people would actually vote
remain now if there was another
referendum but that's not the point
and the 2.5 percent margin on a poem
takes its Koerner back to work well you
could say that rendom itself then
couldn't you but that's not my point my
point is if we look at what's happening
this to dealing precisely this deal is
likely to be a disaster and so therefore
it doesn't hurt to go back to the people
to say this is what breaks it now means
before we didn't know what breaks it
meant but once we have the terms of the
deal we know what breaks it will mean
and what I'm saying is that I think is
jeremy corbyn's duty no just let me
finish let me finish please because if
you look at his base whether that be
young people all momentum they are
pro-eu and i believe it's his lot
7 out of 10 constituencies from time
let me finish I believe is the duty to
go back to those people and make the
case as to why it let's just reach
slightly reposition this because I'm not
going to quite any polls I'm simply
going to quote what I do every single
weekday which is I talk to people on a
regular basis as they phone it to my
radio show and respecting your position
I believe there is a sense now just get
on there bloody well get on with it we
are sick and with due respect 67% of
this 54% of this forget it get on and do
it I think there's a sense of what's
best for Britain that's the conversation
what being had the problem you've got is
the coal bin is not a remainer I never
was you know was mr. McDonald I remember
sitting next to me just before the
referendum I said what's your feeling on
he says we're marginally in favor and I
don't think it was a positive favorable
stage but I don't think they were but of
course the Labour Party is and the
Labour Party always has been and it's
very interesting to see this thing about
democracy in the labour party you know
we have believed in democracy and the
Labour Party - it doesn't suit that's
all political leadership's in all
parties but the Labour Party is without
doubt but it believes him remain and
they want us to remain it happen I do
think it will happen I do think we will
have a general election at some stage in
the next but I think if he made labour
the party of remained that's his number
10 and also just to add to that Greg I
think the reason why labour voters voted
breaks it's very different to the reason
why conservative voters voted breaks it
and he needs to make the case that he
will actually address their concerns
with the Lib Dems if you look at the
last election that was their policy and
they virtually got a blip but I think
the Lib Dem vote is different to those
working-class voters it's a diff there
were specific reasons as to why they
poll the other durjan if you saw it
which said that some nice high 60s
percent was another referendum but with
no no but when they asked them when they
asked them how would they vote
it was exactly it was 50/50 and that
I believe Calvin has to go and make the
case and betray all his incisions but
[Laughter]
listen to my show obviously they just
have enough just get it done I was
contemplating falling asleep but I
thought it would be rude honestly now I
do I just think that we we've had the
vote every day people are like like
changing math you're asking now for some
guy to pretend to be something that is
not in order to go against the people
that voted for his part in order to
support an agenda do something just such
a simple question which is actually so
and this is the trouble while we are I
mean the person I'm when you look back
in history when history look those I
think Cameron will be seen just as Blair
was always gonna be seen in back so
Cameron is going to be always seen as
the person who did this for the politics
of the Tory Party no other reason hasn't
worked
I've almost got anything right yesterday
we know we voted you know I know people
you're on that 21% I want to reverse it
it's not gonna happen what we have to do
is get people we have to get together
and make this work because it's gonna
happen and it needs to be good
unfortunately virus is not the messenger
for that